Genau, dann gehen wir noch zu den Wailoops weiter.
Und die Wailoops,
das ist auch eine Art von Schleife,
also wir kennen ja die einere Schleife,
das war die Vorloop,
und jetzt haben wir auch noch diese Wailoop,
und die Wailoop ist ein bisschen speziell.
Wie ihr seht,
übersetzt ist das so, was wie so lange
diese Bedingung erfüllt ist,
und wird das Ganze
in einer Endloschleife,
oder wird das praktisch diese Ausweisung ausführen.
Das heißt,
hier haben wir eine Kondition,
wenn ihr euch zurückerinnert,
das haben wir es auch beim IF,
das heißt praktisch, es ist sehr ähnlich zum IF,
nur wird das Ganze
einfach wiederholt,
solange diese Kondition TRUE ist.
Also das ist wieder ein Bolian hier,
das schaut dann ungefähr so aus.
Zum Beispiel haben wir hier eine Variable X,
die wir mit 0 definieren,
und solange X
als 3 wiederholt sich das Ganze,
und wie ihr es schon seht,
können das auch zu Problemen führen,
weil sagen wir zum Beispiel,
wir vergessen das hier,
was glaubt ihr, was passiert?
Also, wir vergessen hier
X zu inkrementieren mit 1.
Genau, da haben wir eine Endloschleife,
weil praktisch hier
X nie verändert wird,
das heißt X bleibt immer 0,
das heißt,
das hier ist praktisch immer wahr,
und wir kommen da nicht mehr raus.
Und das kann euch vielleicht auch
beim Live-Programmen passieren,
also da hatten wir über die Jahre
schon öfters Problemen,
dass jemand eine Weilschleife definiert
und vergisst das hier zu machen,
dass praktisch diese Variable,
die wir hier in der Bedingung haben,
nicht verändert
und dann plötzlich reagiert
mein JupyterLab nicht mehr
in Wirklichkeit schon,
es ist nur eine Endloschleife,
die praktisch ewig durchläuft.
Da kann man natürlich auch wieder,
also wir können das mal ausprobieren,
was passiert, wenn man so eine Endloschleife gerät,
die einfachste wäre,
zum Beispiel,
while true,
also,
so lange war,
machen wir irgendwas,
so,
jetzt läuft das hier,
läuft, läuft, läuft, läuft,
und das hört nicht mehr auf,
und da können wir dann einfach hier,
das hier,
manuell sagen,
okay, wir stoppen hier,
und kommt dieses Keyboard interrupt,
ganz interessant bei Jupyter
ist so, also wenn ihr das in Notebook macht,
dann speichert er trotzdem
noch diesen Wert, das heißt,
wir können den auch mal auslesen,
und jetzt wissen wir,
wie oft diese Weisschleife
während diesen fast 14 Sekunden
hier durchlaufen ist,
das heißt, wir haben hier
eine Million
33 Millionen
Nein, 336 Millionen mal ist
diese Weisschleife in der Zwischenzeit durchlaufen.
Genau,
aber für was
verwendet man so eine Weisschleife eigentlich?
Für was ist das notwendig?
Also,
sagen wir zum Beispiel,
ihr wollt ein Programm machen,
das zum Beispiel
so eine Attaschenrechner,
dann könnt ihr eben
hier schauen,
okay, ich will so lange
Sachen addieren,
oder eben hier zum Beispiel
machen wir einfach so eine Art
Papageide und sind immer wieder das,
das rausschreibt,
was wir reingeschrieben haben.
Und wir schauen einfach, bis dieser Input
quitt ist, das heißt praktisch,
wenn ich dann immer ein Input quitt reinschreib,
dann ist
diese
diese Condition
nicht mehr erfüllt, weil, wie ihr hier seht,
haben wir hier einen Ungleich,
also dieses Rufenzeichen macht
das Ganze nicht gleich,
und sobald das nicht mehr erfüllt ist,
bricht die Schleife ab
und dann bändet unser Programm.
Genau,
nochmal zu Endloschleifen, also da gibt es eben
wie gesagt, die einfachste ist diese
Wild True Schleife,
Wild True ist immer wahr,
und die bricht praktisch nie mehr ab.
Und was kann man da
sonst noch so machen,
wenn wir euch zurückerinnern,
wir können hier entweder so
das machen, aber wir können das Ganze
auch so machen, dass wir einfach sagen,
wir haben eine Endloschleife,
und dann, wenn ihr euch zurückerinnert,
gibt es hier dieses Break Statement,
mit der wir praktisch die Schleife
abbrechen können.
Da können wir einfach so ein tolles If
reinhauen, und das macht eigentlich
nichts anderes, wie das, was da vorgemacht
wurde.
Hier im Gegensatz schauen wir aber,
wirklich, der Usain would quit
es, also nicht, nicht gleich,
sondern ist gleich quit.
Genau.
Ist das soweit klar, oder
soll ich da nochmal kurz was wiederholen?
Okay.